visit to Glu Mobile who are all hard at
work on my new Gordon Ramsay - let's
just not be chicken hey hey why enough
is going on it's been so great working
with the - team here at glue they really
understand what it takes to make a great
cooking game rethus honestly if flag has
got an action verbs come on you can do
better than that
I just thought cop and think again will
you yes yes chef honestly I really love
but looking again the art style
it's got great aesthetics amazing
attention to detail who animates this
character it's not those secondly
animation to it if you want to play with
dolls I'll stay at home with a [ __ ]
kids sorry will reduce yeah the really
good news for me is that every team
member is an expert here include and
they really know what they're doing it's
like having the perfect kitchen team did
you can test this because the only thing
you're testing right now is my feet
patience run through your test pad man
on assure in a nutshell it's been an
absolute delight working with the - team
wood glue they are a very talented
really sophisticated group of people
yeah and tied up the graphics on level
three with you yes yep Muppet turn up
the heat and download porn NZ - for free
is this game gonna kick ass I can't hear
ya keep it going